non-minimalists
what do you wish you had done earlier in
your process to minimize
quicker slash become happier quicker
here's the thing guys happiness is the
wrong
pursuit happiness is ephemeral
and if you're always chasing ephemeral
things
then you're always going to feel the
pang of discontent tweet that podcast
sean
and and and so the thing that i'll add
on top of that the right pursuit
is a more meaningful life and so instead
of pursuing happiness
pursue what a meaningful life means for
you not the meaning of life that's
another difficult question i saw a bunch
of people ask us that question on
twitter today
for the lightning round i've got a
couple twitter questions several what's
the purpose of what's the meaning of
life
i don't know i'll start i'll i'll all
divulge
or digress into a
nihilistic sort of rant if you ask me
that i mean i'll say the growth and
contribution is ultimately the meaning
of life
i think there's no point to life and
it's actually freeing for me
to realize that there isn't a point to
any of this let me so the it depends
what we mean by point right and so
maybe there are better questions this
the the meaning of what's the meaning of
life is not a great question
how do i become happier all the time bad
question
and and the better question is what does
a meaningful life look like
to you now for me that means my values
i'm really clear what my values are
and my actions align with what those
values are
and whenever i slip whenever i fall off
the path then
all of a sudden i realize that
discontent is coming from not because
all of a sudden i'm not happy but
because my
values are are not being met in a way
so kenneth with your question here man
if i could if josh and i could give you
a pill
right now we'll send you a pill in the
mail it'll make you
as happy as you've ever been
they do have pills for that uh it's
called mdma
and then you take the mdma again the
next day
and then you take it the third day and
then you take it the fourth day and then
you take it the fifth day
um that it will start to become your new
norm
so i guess maybe a better way said the
mdma example is not
that's not my best thing no i think it's
a great example because there's a crash
after you take into account
there absolutely is great so talk about
that because people go to burning man
and they take mdma for two or three days
and all of a sudden
they're like they're they're miserable
for several days
that's a perfect analogy yeah yeah yeah
i guess yeah and that in that sense it
is the other thing i was going to say
too though is
so kenneth even if you know josh and i
could flip a switch right now and make
you
wake up every morning ecstatic that
that's manic yes and uh
manic people like at their you know at
the extreme version of it
like people who are truly truly manic
like happy
and excited about life well there
a lot of the times they are out in the
street
directing traffic and and haven't been
asked to direct traffic right exactly
like kenneth um
you don't want to be in the street
directing traffic because because that
person who is
who is extremely manic they truly
they're in the street
they're happy about life and they're
like oh i can help traffic flow better
i'm just going to take initiative and do
this
yeah a truly a truly happy person
is when i say truly happy uh ex
an extremely happy person would be manic
and
manic at its terminus um is is is a
mental
illness yeah absolutely i mean my father
was manic depressive and he had those
fits where
where he i mean and he was also
schizophrenic so he
he had full long happy conversations
with people who did not exist in the
real world
and uh and yeah you don't want to be
there but what does a meaningful life
look like to you what are your values go
back and listen to our values podcast
episode it's episode
69 and if you want to get really clear
on your values my partner
and rebecca and i um we go through our
values
all the time and she has like a little
one-page worksheet
based on what we go through it's
minimalwellness.com
values i feel like we really wasted
episode 69 on
the episode values hey but
we did that we already did the sex
episode that was with with chris
that should have been anyway whatever
your way to 169
there was there there's one more thing i
want to add okay and maybe maybe you
said this and i missed it milburn
but uh if you pursue a meaningful life
if your short-term actions are aligning
with those long-term values and beliefs
the beautiful thing is is you do have
happiness
as a byproduct it is not you're not
going to wake up every single morning
and you know uh ride to work on a
unicorn going down rainbow road
uh but but you will you will find more
meaning to your life
and when you when you are able to do
things that uh that that
are good for yourself whether it's
health or whether it's bringing in good
relationships
or whether it's contributing beyond
yourself um
after you after you do those things
that's when that's when i feel happy is
when i
when i have those actions uh when i take
those actions that are in alignment with
those those core values but you're
and the key there is that wasn't the
ideal outcome it was the byproduct
itself
absolutely is fleeting happiness is yeah
fulfillment is the goal yeah yeah i mean
well and there isn't even a goal for me
like i i don't want there to be a goal i
want there to be a direction
and and i think that that that's the
that's the important thing
is is what is my direction my direction
is to live a more meaningful life to
grow
in that direction and yes i'll be
happier
more on the aggregate when i'm living a
meaningful life
there will there i could do a whole
bunch of really stupid
irresponsible stuff and be happy in the
moment
right but eventually you're just like oh
why did i do that
yeah and and and longer term the
aggregate happiness is gonna be much
less when when you do that